[Music]
[Applause]
okay now I'll tell you why I think this
is healthy this is a segment where we
tell viewers try to find a mistake on
our show I think that shows a lot of
confidence on our part right and that
we're very open okay
now so far in the number of years we've
been here hundreds of challengers not
one winner yeah
nobody has ever caught us making mistake
we will own up to a mistake we just
don't make them we've never made a
mistake don't make a witty to make
mistake I know I've never made any no
maybe I should have done for Burt's Bees
[Laughter]
hard to know whether they're agreeing
whether they agree with her they can't
tell oh well I know assume they're on my
side of course any who's we don't make
mistakes we just don't well tonight a
fan named Shane says he thinks he caught
a mistake he says it happened when I
showed how crazy my knight got after I
took a shot of tequila won't even take a
look christow Texas and I'm 100% sure I
found an error in your May first episode
when you Amy you seem to have jose not
great idea you I try changes some
batteries in a smoke detector
[Music]
[Music]
you think he's got me you don't yeah
yeah well first of all I gotta say
something to this guy you made the
mistake your first mistake was shooting
your segment underwater what kind of
audio was he using I don't know it's so
ridiculous because he knows he's known
by Aquaman
well I'm sorry Shane to burst your
bubble but you are dead wrong you
assumed that was a smoke detector but it
wasn't it's an alarm for something very
different
check out this instructional video for
the alarm that I actually was using in
that segment part 2 how to insert the
batteries I don't know why this isn't
working these are brand new batteries
well remember ma'am it's not a smoke
detector it's a fake
cowboy detector and the batteries in a
fake cowboy detector go in backwards go
on try it on some stupid person on the
Internet
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we also happy about a bunch of people
just got killed good lord
somehow the water ignited yeah yeah it
happens and I don't want some nerds out
there writing us in about that water can
ignite a flame any who's we're right
again and you're wrong now the challenge
still stands if you think you've spotted
an error on our show reported at Team
Coco comm slash haha I found an error
we'll sorted out right here on the air
let's see if you've got what it takes to
make chunk meat out of the maestro
[Applause]
you